A
HAS DIED ANDRECOE ON MY VEHIGAND
NO COUNTECTION THE F
OHMR. IT LIVESND MOSTLYSOIL. SOG
IT SIMPLY BY IN THE FUNGAL SPOR.
. HE'S THE VIAN PETERSON
THERE. IHI HE IS WIT
US MAY N
YOU HEAR YOU'ROKAY
? YES, I H TNK
JOININ WIT WE KN T
ONE PE HD?ENLLITCTORS FAMILY? WI
HA NOT BEEN COCTTATRACTOAMWEROME
E
, IN IN THE
MIDDLE, ASS THAT
OF STUFF. WE'RE
COOPERATING WITHHE DO
YO PEOPLE ARE GETTINGSICK? THERD
RE GETTING I SRE ALLNANAS YOU
SAID,AI IN IN
WET SOINGFROM TNGHERE'S
O
DSHETE
E DO
WHAT'S CAL HEALTAR, WHICHY G PHN
TOCHO TRY TOPLINIDLE THE MAIL TU
SO WE YEARS THIS M'LL COMMENCE T
CLEANING. OKAY SO YOU'VE IDLED
AIR FOR PEOO CLEAN MAKE SURE TS
SICK. CATH PEOPLE
LEARNED THAT IN
INVESTAT WELLNOT AN EXPER IN BLG
FAIRLY QUICK, SO WLDYOU TOALE CG
JUST FINE IOUBOATALITYSOWNLER  W
SETH
WITH THE UTMOST SERIOUSNEHA
TO U
WHAT WE KNO
COMPLEX MTLUNVENTILATION SYSTEMD
AREAS  PEOTA
IS THE FIRST TIME IITHE WORLD. ?
R PERSONALLY
OF ANY OUTBREAHIS,
IS NATIVAROF
HERE'SEV BUT
FO, THERE'S NEVER BANOUTRAG THIS
MILL OR OR A M
BEEND. AND IS THERET YOU BELIEVN
THE CDCT'SU.
ANDE ORIGINATESNEH, YOU KNO
INTOHE. I MEAN, IF I THE ATE ANE
AND THEN U MA
WHEOU
REALLY TRYING TOSTANDN ALLHESE R
TR GET THE R CAUSEMMON,
TOWARDS YOU KNOW THE AE GOINGO
PELE IS HOLEYO
L WILL BE BACK,
FUY  AND SAFE
FOR PEOPLE TO UIGHT NOW
PLANNING UEKS TOGE W
A KNOW, AND SVOLVING
HAUS FINISHED UP
EXPERTS THARKED WITHNIIDDLE EANA
LOT ASHEREEW DAY